bienvenue dans paf paf vous le savez
c'est cette émission dans laquelle on
discute de l'actualité on en débat aussi
et aujourd'hui on a un sommaire
absolument chargé puisque on reviendra
évidemment sur les élections
départementales on tirera les
conséquences de ces élections
départementales peut-être aussi on en
parlera de manière prospective qu'est-ce
que ça annonce pour le futur on verra
aussi il ya eu l'élection des présidents
verra que malgré la parité qui avait
lieu dans les élections il ya quand même
peu de femmes qui sont présidentes de
département
on parlera aussi des propos de jean
marie le pen qui réitère ses propos qui
avait été condamné sur la deuxième
guerre mondiale notamment et sur donc
sur sa stratégie vis-à-vis du front
national et vis-à-vis de sa fille qui
préside le mouvement
on parlera aussi de la grève à radio
france qui se poursuit et de la
situation son pdg mathieu gallet est ce
qu'il va pouvoir rester en place et puis
un sujet très intéressant qu'on appelle
un peu lui mais risation de la société
vous connaissez la firme hubert qui fait
des taxis à la place des taxis il ya
aussi booking.com qui essaye de se
mettre à la place des hôteliers on en
parlera notamment avec jean-luc madec
donc un sommaire très chargé pour en
parler stéphane manceau bonjour vous
êtes de professeur à l'université de
droit de versailles saint quentin
doyon noir de cette même université de
même faculté de droit par florence faire
qu'elle est choquée avocate au barreau
de versailles
on parlera aussi tiens d'un à petit fait
divers intéressant c'est c'est un homme
qui a détruit son bracelet électronique
et ce n'est pas considéré comme une
évasion vous nous expliquerez peut-être
pourquoi jean luc madec patrice ça va
vous êtes attaqués parce que on va
parler réellement de vos amis de
booking.com etc etc
il y en a d'autres d'autres sites et
puis à un nouveau qui est vincent la
boue c'est moi
grasset vous êtes vous êtes étudiant un
troisième est en troisième année
c'est ça un journalisme c'est que selon
autorise donc vous êtes un futur juriste
j'espère et nous espérons aussi eh ben
vous pourrez prendre 2 voilà exemple
quelqu'un qui a été journaliste qui ne
l'est plus c'est en fermage monique et
éditeurs voilà il a changé de casquette
se changer de casquette
voilà mais c'est ça aussi vous êtes
toujours dans les crimes voilà oui puis
j'ai pas renoncer définitivement je
réalise non plus absolument alors la
grève à radio france et cette situation
assez assez incroyable c'est à dire que
on a un pdg qui s'appelle mathieu gallet
qui a été nommé par le csa qui est une
instance indépendante qui n'était pas le
candidat du pouvoir puisqu'il avait été
auparavant au cabinet notamment de
frédéric mitterrand dont quelques uns
qui était classé plutôt à droite ya une
grève de radio france il ya une attitude
du gouvernement à son égard qui est
assez forte par exemple la ministre dit
j'ai convoqué le président de radio
france qui ne se fait pas généralement
comment vous avez divisés cette grève
est est justement ses conséquences sur
la présence d'une main sur le président
de radio france et sur le fait que de la
question se pose est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
ou non se maintenir mais déjà on en est
je crois au 16e ou 15e ou 16e c'est de
la grosse balle absolument gigantesque
et en fait c'est toutes les antennes
sont paralysés par moins de 10% de
grévistes
c'est vraiment ça déjà c'est un truc
totalement aberrant 10% d'une boîte de
4500 salariés puissent mettre à genoux
toutes les antennes du service public
honte à moi j'ai été longtemps en
défense ça fera taire il suffisait qu'
une personne qui se déclarent grévistes
pour que l'émission une émission de
presse par aller voilà mais c'est un
véritable scandale cela il devrait y
avoir quand même une sorte de queue
comme pour le transport public ophélia
un service minimum obligatoire et
l'amérique oui mais c'est très cher payé
sur france info sur france culture sur
france inter on entend de la musique
c'est très bien c est pitoyable
en plus en pleine période électorale ou
jeu derrière un véritable manque et je
veux dire on a l'impression que ça va
durer va se lasser annoncé maintenant
même il n'ya même pas de discussions
face et ce pendant 5 jours en corse est
totalement dément après la situation du
président c'est vrai que je veux dire le
gouvernement ils se conduisent pire que
ce que jamais un ministre sarkozyste
aurait osé faire est ce qu'on est et ce
qu'on imagine ce si un ministre de la
culture de sarkozy avait osé convoqué un
patron du service public mais ça serait
la révolution
alors que l'annoncé fleur pellerin bon
elle n'a pas le temps de lire mais là le
temps de qu'on veut qu'il combattrait
bien qu'on veut mais c'est scandaleux
vingt ans j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
sorte de lynchage médiatique contre
mathieu gallet un petit peu quand on
voit ce qu'il est déjà scellé médiatique
ou est-ce que c'est politique c'est il
ya un peu des deux mais quand on regarde
le canard enchaîné qui balance
ils sont utiles car bien sûr mais je
sens qu'un break une fixette sur mathieu
gallet qui peut-être n'est pas ou n'est
pas légitime et d'un peu jeune quels ont
été les choix c'est bien la jeunesse
mais est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi de
l'expérience il est à li na mais est ce
que ces formalités de douane elles
étaient dans des cabinets ministériels
ça bouge quand même beaucoup moins que
il est échoué non à l'europe en génie
doublement cas précis le csa jean luc
c'est ubu c'est ubu le monde du bus
payés par les deniers publics
je crois qu'on se fout du monde tant pis
pour eux que s'ils sont pas capables de
régler leurs problèmes et bien place
radio libre radio privée dans la clape
donc emma voilà désolé pour france inter
et le reste c'est court 10h15 hyrule
bien sûr favori culture la transe gaule
a été en grève pendant près d'un mois
vous parlez pourtant la galette est
particulièrement dur mais encore une
fois seulement au début et c'est payé
par les deniers publics si tu permets
juste une chose il ya beaucoup moins de
différences entre france 2 et tf1 contre
france inter et rosario terre donc il ya
une véritable spécificité du service
public alors qu'il ya nulle part
ailleurs donc une grève la télévision
sera pas de pub mais oui mais on
l'appelle la différence on voit plein la
différence lance une chasse à l'homme
qui a été engagée probablement par
certains syndicats par le gouvernement
chasse est d'accord qui est un espèce de
mixed syndicalisme et politique dans
cette histoire que mathieu gallet
n'était pas le candidat du gouvernement
et je trouve c'est particulièrement
dommage parce que radio france est dans
une situation financière quand même
assez catastrophique il avait un plan de
restructuration mais finalement on vu de
l'extérieur on a l'on sait pas très bien
pourquoi ils font grève s'ils font grève
parce que il l'a fait cent vingt mille
euros de dépenses dans son bureau ou si
c'est parce qu'ils se rencontrent ou si
c'est parce que vraiment ils sont contre
les mesures de repas une si longue
lettre il ya donc
enfin bon j'ai une espèce de mixed
politiques syndicales syndicats et c'est
vraiment dommage d'avoir radio france
effectivement en silence radio avec de
la musique mais enfin depuis quinze
jours c'est je pense que les
journalistes qui ont envie de travailler
doivent être très frustré de pas avoir
pu participer aux commentaires de voix
il exclut les avec le mental c'est un
grand nombre d'auditeurs son profond
respect que des techniciens ont plus qu
ils font grève
oui là des journalistes ont fait grève
hier je croise entière certainement oui
parce que là quand même aussi le truc qu
ils veulent pas de vous parler non mais
je vais être très bref on a laissé juste
l'attitude de la cour des comptes
on n'a jamais vu ça c'est à dire qu'en
pleine grève en plein conflit il rajoute
de l'huile sur le feu et détient ou fait
coucou nous on va vous dire il faut
mixer les trois rédactions ce qui fait
qu effectivement comme le dit rien au
monde les journalistes qui n'étaient pas
en grève se mettent en grève mais merci
la cour des comptes
voilà on peut vraiment penser d une
véritable cabale parce que c'est la
première fois que la cour des comptes
qui enfin se se mêle d'un conflit comme
ça je présente la danse que notre
éminent professeur de droit est ce
qu'ils ont le droit de le faire je sais
pas
l'éminent professeur de droit en fin de
ce point de vue juridique on n'en pense
pas grand chose mais moi en tant que
usagers puisque on parle du service
public de radio france moi je trouve le
temps long
parce que la radio de qualité sont
publicité moi j'aime bien notamment le
matin et je suis un auditeur à ses
fidèles de spécifiquement de deux
chaînes de radio france alors mathieu
gallet a peut-être un peu donné des
bâtons pour se faire battre aussi oui
les deniers publics oui c'est 23 euros
par an et par foyer fiscal
grosso modo je trouve que ça les vaut 2
euros par mois par foyer fiscal pour
avoir un pool de chaînes de radio de
service public plus alors vous l'avez
dit dédé des orchestres etc alors oui
c'est du luxe a tenu du très bien mais
partant de là tout ce qui est culturel
c'est du luxe à choisir la convenu césar
desseix la question à quoi sert la main
à quoi sert la beauté fondamentalement à
rien mais c'est ce qui nous fait vivre
bon donc moi je alors ce qui me choque
en revanche alors oui il ya peut-être
toujours cette espèce de deux mauvaises
habitudes ou rtf voilà ministère de
l'information qui n'existe plus on sait
que le pouvoir politique est un peu
devrait être un peu plus habile pour
régler ses relations vis-à-vis de
l'audiovisuel peu à peu on y vient mais
lorsque moi ce qui me choque c'est quand
j'entends ou quand je lis que sarkozy
lui en tire la conclusion suivante qu'il
faut revenir à l'ancien système c'est à
dire le meilleur public va nommer
directement parce que soi-disant avant
c'était totalement hypocrite donc plutôt
que de que de soigner le malade
eh bien on va le tuer et comme ça tout
ira bien mais est-ce qu'il ya quand même
de la part de pouvoir l'envi de
reprendre demain ce qu'il va y avoir
dans dans les semaines qui viennent dans
les mois qui viennent mois de mai la
nomination du nouveau président de
france télévisions est-ce que c'est pas
une façon pour le gouvernement de dire
au csa ce coup ci nous fait pas à coups
en douce en nommant quelqu'un qui n'est
pas candidat du pouvoir
moi je trouve qu'il ya assez largement
sans doute de la part du gouverneur des
gouvernants des normes fantasme mais
qu'est ce qu'on imagine
est ce qu'on imagine que parce que on va
placer à la tête de ses dires de ses
organes de presse énorme avec des
journalistes qui quand même sont formés
obéissent à une déontologie je crois que
c'est assez fort la déontologie
journalistique et que comme ça tout seul
toutes ces équipes vont avoir le doigt
sur la couture du pantalon et livré ce
que le pseudo ministre de l'information
leur a dit dire mais c'est un vieux
fantasme
ce qui est très troublant c'est qu'en
plus à france inter c'est vraiment une
radio de gauche donc le gouvernement
devrait être ravi de dire tous les
matins je viens c'est la bonne parole du
parti royaliste qui est délivrée avec
beaucoup de talent et sa liste des noms
mais c'est incroyable qu'un gouvernement
se tire une balle dans clé ils seront
jamais mieux servi que par ce que par
les gens que par les gens qui bossent en
ce moment donc il faut annuler des
soutenez enfin c'était hier
l'hystérie l'on peut bientôt plus de
pied parce que vous allez vers les
radios privées maintenant que service
public savait qu'il arrive une chose
assez étrange autant aux télévisions les
gens ozap facilement autant à radio les
gens ont des habitudes et des habitudes
se changent très très lentement
on verra ce que vont donner les
prochaines audiences et pastur que radio
france perdent énormément à cause de la
grève ça peut avoir des conséquences à
plus long terme peut-être pas dans la
prochaine vague d'audience mais enfin on
le verra cependant la question j'ai
essayé de zap effectivement sur rtl sur
europe 1 mais j'ai fui parce que il y
avait une balle assez insupportable et
donc je suis une fidèle auditrice depuis
des années de certaines chaînes de radio
france est très bénéfique et mais je
suis frustré de
je suis frustré de commentaires positifs
pas du tout non plus les journaux à je
lis les journaux
voyez je lis les journaux et j'aime et
je retrouve pas l'équivalent de ce que
j'avais sur france inter sur toile sur
france culture téléphone on repasse aux
élections départementales on a été dit
sur ce sujet on va peut-être commencer
par l'analyse des résultats victoire
delà de la droite c'est indéniable mais
de quel droit tu es ce que c'est ce que
c'est la droite dure est-ce que c'est la
droite qui s'allie avec le centre est ce
que au fossé du victoire de sarkozy
parce qu'il est président de l'ump mais
est-ce que c'est pas une victoire de
l'élite juppé n'ont pas pressé je sais
pas mais c'est quand même l'union de la
droite et du centre
non pas vraiment enfin je suis c'est une
victoire de la droite une victoire de
l'ump clair et net je veux dire le front
national a bien résumé tout ça a fait un
score enfin je ne dirais pas de je crois
qu'il n'y a aucune ambiguïté je leur ai
expliqué le dessinateur humoristique
c'était dans le monde d'hier pourquoi de
tizé mais c'est clair et net les gens
veulent plus de gauche donc ils ont voté
à droite
non mais j'y vois là bon là c'est clair
et net les gens ont voté pour
on ne peut pas vraiment parler de
programmer la salle à droite encore
m'enfin bon pour un espoir d'un jour un
programme qui ont voté pour lui pour une
droite normal probablement décomplexée
c'est très bien et voilà ils ont refusé
de voter à gauche s'ils votent à droite
mais il n'y a pas de mélanges à faire
avec une droite dure de la droite dure
la droite extrême c'est front national
c'est clair c'est à dire et dans tous
les départements pour beaucoup de
départements c'était une alliance ump et
des maisons qu'ils l'alliance de la
droite et du centre
ce que c'est pour ça qu'il dit est ce
que c'est bien une victoire d'alain
juppé puisque c'est ce qu'il propose lui
il un bon été préférable que le centre
soit mieux marquer il n'a jamais réussi
à l'être hélas et pourtant dieu si si
depuis les années 70 on a tout essayé
pour faire exister un centre dans ce
pays il est clair que si le centre
avaient été respectées comme tel nous
n'aurions pas vu une telle émergence du
front national sur la droite est restée
la droite la gauche la gauche et le
centre ont existé évident qu'aujourd'hui
l'écrasement du centre par la droite
traditionnelle a laissé émerger le front
national c'est une hélas une observation
qu'on fait depuis maintenant
pratiquement 40 ans et personne n'a
réussi à résoudre le problème la seule
personnalité émergente était françois
bayroux qui a fait 2 plutôt de bons
résultats en 2007 qui n'ont pas été
confirmées en 2012 c'est dommageable
et puis il se trouve aussi que nous
avons fait une promotion absolument
incroyable pour la famille le pen on va
parler de la famille global
voilà c'est tout revend les marques
postales c'est toujours une véritable
marque de fabrique
on parle même pas vraiment de fond de
front national ou de l'extrême droite on
parle de la famille le pen et c'est
devenu une marque met d'ailleurs
l'accent à la table la victoire de la
droite républicaine a pas pour l'instant
de florence par exemple vous met à nu
les et comment j'ai plutôt tendance à
penser que c'est plutôt la ligne juppé
qui ont dit qu'ils seraient plutôt
gagnante dans cette dans cette opération
même si gp va attendre un peu mais on a
sarko nicolas sarkozy sur l'entre-deux
tours qui a quand même fait droite forte
avec le problème du lait là des cantines
et c'est donc il est allé essayer de
grignoter sur sur l'extrême droite
et puis de l'autre côté avec un centre
droite normale entre guillemets donc je
sais pas si cette espèce d'union un peu
factice mais un peu comme à gauche qui
n'a pas marché d'ailleurs mais cette
union va forcément un moment ou un autre
va se fissurer parce qu'ils vont pas
réussir à 60 ans notre moi je suis enfin
je suis très partagé parce que enfin les
résultats de ce point de vue là mangani
illisible complètement veut dire que
l'un et l'autre disait ma stratégie qui
l'emportent
alors c'est vrai et florence a raison ou
lui ai rien demandé au sujet des
cantines scolaires et essaye de régler
un problème qui ne se pose pas le voile
à l'université alors la question a pu se
poser dans certaines universités de
manière très très isolée mais
globalement il n'y a pas de difficultés
donc la stratégie affichée de ce côté là
c'est en effet encore une fois de faire
comme en 2007 c'est à dire d'essayer de
siphonner les voix du front national
parce que on sait bien que le front
national
si si populaire soit-il n'est pas jugée
par les français comme étant apte à
gouverner
bon donc autant siphonner l'électorat de
ce point de vue là et puis de l'autre
oui la ligne juppé et moi qui me semble
nettement plus rationnelle mais la
rationalité en politique je sais pas si
ça si ça conduit à la victoire
cette ligne juppé elle se trouve en
effet conforté par le fait que
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de victoire
possible au regard du tripartisme
électorale qui s'installe et on a un
bipartisme institutionnel mais un tri
partenaires politiques
je crois que nul ne peut gagner seul et
l'ump seule ne pourra plus le ps tous à
la presse comme ps ont craint parce que
je suis très étonné parce que avec vos
propos à tous les deux ça renforce vous
le faites pas exprès j'imagine peu à peu
le front national et de façon incroyable
c'est à dire que dès que quelqu'un
s'intéresse aux problèmes posés par
l'islamisme tout de suite c'est arrive à
siphonner les voix de l'extrême droite
si jamais si on peut rêver mais si le
parti socialiste
si l'ump et si le centre n'ont parlé
jean-luc de temps en temps aux et dire
oui il ya un problème avec l'islam
oui un problème de voix dans les
facultés plutôt que de dire ça n'existe
pas je viens de passer y avait encore
des femmes voilées qui sortait
de l'université l'instant dix minutes
avant avant l'émission ça existe alors
le sentent tous les partis bien bien
bien confortable un peu bobo mais non ça
n'existe pas de ce qu'ils mettent ils
ont faim n'ayons pas peur etc
et pendant ce temps là le front national
mais se rengorge fait le plein de voix
parce que c'est le seul parti qui a dit
qu' effectivement je paraphrase fabius
qui apporte une mauvaise réponse mais là
dessus il pose les vraies questions
les français sont interposés pas trop
d'accord de dire à chaque fois quand il
n'y a pas de problème mais si un
problème olé quand on prend l'avion soit
la france et que dans sur le plateau
repas il ya un petit papier en disant
rassurez-vous ce que ce plateau ne
contient pas de porc il ya un problème
moi j'ai un problème je ne veux pas
prendre l'avion de la compagnie
nationale et qu'on me force à et qu'on
me précise je suis en france je suis pas
sûr à jerry je veux je veux pouvoir
manger du porc si j'ai envie de manger
du porc on n'a pas de le préciser
c'est un scandale absolu là où il ya une
ambiguïté dans ce qu'ils disaient c'est
que les tous les repas de substitution
le problème du port c'est pas que un
problème d'islam ceux-ci des gamins ils
sont végétariens ceci des gamins qui ont
décimé bien sûr que si au départ quand
on parle pas d'un problème halal mais
parce que aucun ne s'est pas qu'un
problème est donc je touche deux espèces
d'assimilation donc quand il dit il faut
arrêter de manger du porc il
il en train de stigmatiser une
population sans ticket pour manger du
porc mais c'est pas grave c'est ça l'art
osé vous la posez la poussée continue
avec le truc sous le tapis et puis on
verra dans en 2017
moi je pense que c'est un problème c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas du tout le cas
l'oeuvre le problème n'est pas mis sous
le tapis et jean-charles du conseil
qu'il a sûrement déjà lu le bouquin de
de mon ami laurent bouvet qui s'appelle
la sécurité culturelle est justement
avec lequel je suis totalement en accord
dans lequel il démontre que mieux que je
ne pourrais le faire qu'en effet à trop
vouloir mettre sous le tapis les vrais
problèmes
c'est ce qui fait monter le front
national mais j'ai pas l'impression
justement pour les mettre sur le tapis
clair que parfois il ya des difficultés
mais il faut pas non plus
créer des différentes des difficultés là
existent elles n'existent pas ou pas
encore ou pas au point qu'on doit
stigmatiser les uns ou les autres ou les
uns contre les autres c'est uniquement
ça c'est un jeu politique
un jeu politicien maladroit puisque
l'original est toujours préféré à la
copie et on l'a vu en 2012
bon donc là de ce point de vue là moi je
vois là je alors est ce qu'il ya des
filles voilées à l'université oui moi
j'enseigne depuis une vingtaine d'années
j'ai dû en avoir dans les amphithéâtres
2 alors voilée avec le foulard par les
biens par william alors moi oui est-ce
que ça me choque
je n'entre même pas dans ce débat quand
j'étais doyen de la fac on est plusieurs
fois certains et certaines étudiantes ou
certains mêmes étudiants parfois si on
aime voir en disant on veut changer de
groupe parce que la charge et de t d est
une fille et moi en tant que pratiquant
je peux pas la regarder en face
la réponse a été non non et puis
étudiant il est parti et puis et puis je
sais pas où il est et puis c'est son
problème
voilà donc on peut déjà s'attaque à la
laïcité pour le couvrir bien sûr mais
j'ai aussi des étudiants des étudiants
juifs qui sont venus me dire pas de pas
de contrôle pas de contrôler le vendredi
j'ai eu des étudiants qui voulaient
partir en pèlerinage etc
c'est aujourd'hui mais ça le fréquent
ben non est ce que vous pourriez décaler
les examens n'ont bombardé les propres
ce style de problème on peut les
résoudre mais sans nécessairement monter
les uns contre les autres les gens les
uns contre les autres et le reproche que
je fais justement c'est d'essayer de
créer des difficultés et des clivages
là où justement le principe de laïcité
bien compris permettrait d aplanir
mais c'est que la laïcité soit respecté
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
et quand on va dans les territoires
français croyez-moi elle et les les
français de la base ils disent c'est pas
respecter donc ils cherchent une autre
voie et la grande problématique à
laquelle nous avons fondé aujourd'hui
c'est que les deux grands partis
traditionnels français n'ont pas de
réponse en tout cas n'ont pas eu les
réponses adaptées à la situation et les
français une grande partie d'entre eux
en tout cas rejeté cela est finalement
cherche une autre voie et comme on ne
leur a pas proposé d'autre voie viable
que celle du front national ils vont
vers le front national
c'est dommage mais ce n'est que la
conséquence de l'aveuglément des partis
traditionnels
oui mais ce que l'abbé problème c'est de
savoir si la vigilance consiste à avoir
des problèmes partout même là où il y en
a pas ça va nous demande pas à ce niveau
partout mais en tout cas il y a dans le
quotidien d'un grand nombre de nos
compatriotes tant dans les zones
urbaines que dans les zones rurales les
choses qui aujourd'hui les hearts et il
serait vraiment un plus dans de ne pas
les voir en face vincent vous êtes
confrontés les étudiants et étudiantes
dans l'école non non non sincèrement
dans l'école mais la question que je me
pose c'est que pensent les autres
enseignants à l'université de sur la
question du voile
l'université s'est passé dit c est en
cela la loi de 2004
il faut distinguer puisque les étudiants
sont pas sont pas de simples usagers
d'un service public depuis le 11e siècle
les étudiants alors ce ne sont pas que
des mots parce qu'il ya des incidences
concrètes et juridique les étudiants
forment avec les maîtres une communauté
la communauté universitaire l'université
de bologne la plus ancienne du monde
occidental a été créée par les étudiants
eux-mêmes donc l'étudiant n'est pas un
simple usager on s'adresse à des adultes
c'est des adultes ses joueurs et des
gens souvent des adultes auxquels on
essaie nous d'inculquer un minimum de
sens critique ce n'est pas simple
on essaie d'inculquer une forme
d'apprentissage de la liberté je suis
convaincu qu être libre ça s'apprend
donc voilà il ya un principe de
responsabilité et d'autonomie
d'autonomisation qui conduit à ce qu'on
ne puisse pas regarder nos étudiants
comme étant des lycéens et des
collégiens eux mêmes d'ailleurs se
disent ils les élèves moi je les
retrouve toujours vous n'êtes pas des
élèves vous êtes des ecclésiastiques les
mains puisque on était sur la question
de la droite un mot on va revenir sur
l'élection des présidents et notamment
de pierre bédier dans les yvelines
le conseil départemental des yvelines et
ses deux grand chelem pour la droite
tous les élus sont sourds de droite on a
entendu des gens de gauche qui disent
mais cette pâte démocratique d'avoir que
des élus d'un même qu'ils sont de même
côté qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce sont des ongles rouges qui ont fait
le mode d'emploi de legato ces deux
élections départementales ont fait de
l'héritage qu'il ya pas de solution
alternative accusant m
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose de pas
une bonne chose pour les régionales pas
su finalement nous sommes dans un pays
dans lequel il ya plusieurs strates de
gouvernance et les communes les
départements les régions et l'état
bon maintenant rendez-vous dans les
régionales où le mode de scrutin est
différent de celui des départementales
mais comme dit le chat c'est la gorge ce
qu'a fait la règle du jeu
sur la départementale faut qu'il y ait
de pleurer maintenant par contre
visiblement la forme prise par les
élections aux régionales est un peu
différent puisqu'il ya un mix de la foi
de scrutin majoritaire et proportionnel
donc va rendez-vous région puisque en
réalité quand même ne nous voilons pas
la face moi je suis vent debout depuis
des années sur les strates
administratives avec la folie française
je crois qu'on doit être les deux seuls
dans le monde avec la corée du nord
avoir une telle pléthore de
fonctionnaires il ya un adolescent un
début pour y admirer des ventes et par
dans ce combat notamment des ventes le
chiffre des fans il ya un élu en france
pour 104 habitants
la belle affaire non mais la csn ses
sept millions de gens qui travaillent
dans ce pays pour la fonction publique
elle soit d'état ou territoriale
c'est la course mais encore l'adapter
donc voilà je comprends un mot d'ordre
c'est pas possible on peut pas ne
mélangeons pas on parle d'un côté des
agents publics
très bien alors fonctionnaire les trois
fonctions publiques état collectivités
territoriale hospitalière c'est 5
millions de personnes délégations
nationales à settat et toute la future
bande de l'aide mais je ne vais pas mais
mais les élus ça c'est autre chose
vous avez cinq cent vingt mille élus en
france alors si on rapporte le nombre
d'habitants c'est énorme et sur ses 520
mille élus il y en a une infime minorité
qui reçoivent des indemnités
puisque ces 520 mille élus sont composé
à 90% de conseillers municipaux jeu et
conseil municipal pendant six ans je
peux vous dire que j'ai pas touché un
peu peur et je trouve ça parfaitement
normal bon j'en ai même été de ma poche
sur certains aspects donc c'est pas les
élus qui coûte cher et je reprendrai une
faille une observation que je trouve
très pertinente
alors qui est peut-être discuta mais qui
était celle de bi carcassonne professeur
dans les constitutionnels décédé l'année
dernière et qui disait au fond ces cinq
cent mille élus séparer coup c'est une
économie
c'est une économie parce que pour la
fonction de
et qui est ce qu'on qui est ce qu'on
appelle france rurale c'est 80 85 % des
communes françaises qui ont moins de
2000 habitants
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la nuit quand il
ya un problème c'est pas le garde
champêtre parce que parfois il y en a
pas c'est pas le secrétaire de mairie
parce qu'il ne vit pas la selmer housse
et les adjoints et ça coûte quoi sert un
maire un maire d'une commune de moins de
1000 habitants il reçoit 646 euros brut
par mois
alors ça coûte moins cher que
d'entretenir un large public bon donc
moi je vois là c'est juste je trouve ça
enfin attention et disco et non puis
sais c'est pas alors on a trop d'élus
bas très bien alors supprimons le sénat
et puis élisons j'ai pas un député puis
comme ça ça coûte rapprochait et puis
mettons à présent de la république tout
seul comme ça et j'aimerais bien et les
régions cherchent nous sommes pas
plainte qui va être au début nous nous
sommes plaints qu'il y ait trop de
strates administratives
je n'ai pas montré du doigt les élus je
montre du doigt l'organisation admet
celle d'autres pays qui aujourd'hui
marche sur la tête l'on va très bien que
la sel poivre on agit d'un conseil
départemental en se dédouanant elle vole
inadaptée donc en plus créer une strate
suivante air avec les collectivités
locales avec tes côtés l'agglomération
voilà donc je ne montre pas les et du
doigt et je comprends parfaitement et
entre élus moi même que un grand nombre
d'entre eux contribuent à la gouvernance
publique de façon tout à fait gratuite
je dénonce simplement que dans ce pays
quand on additionne commune plus que tu
l agglomération département région état
plus tout ce qu'il ya autour d'eux les
chambres consulaires etc tard on va sur
la terre nous sommes 7 millions je vous
rappelle quand même que dans ce pays
nous sommes 29 million de travailleurs
dont 7 millions sont au jour
il voué à la collectivité publique je
pense que nous avons là à déséquilibre
qui nous coûte vers une fortune et les
dérives financières de l'état et notre
incapacité à être aujourd'hui un pays
je dirais normalement concurrentiel en
europe vient évidemment de là il va
finir comme je la tenais va finir par fc
erdre et d'amour pour mon pays
ces habitantes et ses habitants et
renversant mais voilà le front national
il faut en parler alors on a été galère
par exemple vous avez dit fondation est
plutôt une victoire est donc on aura
d'élise et l'aider des résultats du
front national là ce qui se passe c'est
la polémique entre papa est membre et
ses filles entre jean marie le pen et
marine le pen et enfin surtout les
propos de jean marie le pen qui a
réitéré ses propos sur
les chambres à gaz de détail de la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui dit bo
front national ni au top et cynique dans
sa playlist que dans ses rues liste et
qui théorisent au fond ça ses propos en
disant mais le front national ne grimpe
que par la provocation non pas par la
banalisation est ce que c'est un bien ou
est ce que c'est un mal pour le front
national c'est la question que je vous
pose d'un présent qui veut embêter sa
fille mangez pas ça tombe pile poil à
cette fois ci c'est pas sûr que ça soit
qu'une impression mais comment ça se
fait à votre avis est-ce parce je pense
qu'ils se vouent une haine politique et
familial je ne sais pas mais de haine
politique veut dire elle a atteint des
sommets que lui n'a jamais tutoyé voilà
c'est clair et net que en plus
honnêtement je pense qu'ils commencent
et un peu gâteux franchement c'est un
peu c'est un peu terrible face et si le
personnage était pas aussi antipathique
on aurait presque pitié quand il
s'exprime quand on le voit la météo va
le déplacer sur sa chaise pour le poser
dans une qualité en plus présente et je
pense avoir la région paca voilà rires
que je suis pas sûr que marine le pen
llc aux ide marine le pen soit enfin
préférez probablement marion maréchal-le
pen je pense qu'ils ont quelque chance
avec marion maréchal-le pen et zone où
aucune avec jean marie c'est une vision
va voir juste 3 monde sait que
finalement la marque le pen elle existe
dans cette marque il ya évidemment de
vision et deux modes de communication et
j'ai le sentiment quelque part parce que
c'est pas nouveau le phénomène de jean
marie c'est que on a envie de ratisser
large et par conséquent autant marine a
une vision un peu je dirais partie
normale où on est c'est d'abandonner 500
soir d'astreinte c'est la surface et en
même temps il ya le papa qui lie ratisse
large ce qu'il ya derrière cette voiture
et en quantité de gens qui lisent bon
bein il est bien gentil
enfin les biens trop douce bien trop
souple bien trop mignonne bien trop
adapté à l'idée reçue que politique
globale donc le papa il ratisse derrière
tous ceux qui sont à la traîne et donc
vous voyez bien que c'est pas le papy
gâteau et il veut ils ont la volonté de
ratisser large baie au même titre
d'ailleurs que nos politiques absurdes
c'est un peu comme
comme on disait autrefois que pétain
était bouclé et des résistants pour ça
qu'ils sont tous les deux d'accord
enfin je pense moi j'ai la conviction
avec deux d'accord d'accord bien sûr au
même titre si je peux me permettre juste
encore une seconde pardon mon cher cette
année parce que ils sont impatients
c'est normal
françois mitterrand quand il a été du
président de la république sur les
propos dont on connaît la consistance et
surtout sur les promesses qu'il avait
faites pour être élu en 81 il a quand
même fait une longue partie de son
mandat un président de droite jacques
chirac quand il a été élu présent à vue
qui a longtemps pratiqué une petite de
gauche
ce à quoi pour objet décès de ratisser
le plus large possible
bon la famille le pen sur une chose je
conduisais dans les talus à droite ou à
gauche vous vers nos centres en france
sur le buzz alors moi je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec jean lui parce que je
pense pas que ce soit un accord tacite
je pense que marine le pen a essayé de
faire du nettoyage de faire quelque
chose d'un peu propre et que son père va
tout prix existait bon après il ya
conflit père finit par faire de la
psychanalyse mais non non non non c'est
désolé donc je pense dans un dans un
mauvais vin dans une piquette y compris
via c'est comme dans les grands dans les
grands vins
quand on secoue la bouteille il ya du
dépôt qui remonte on l'a dit à l'instant
le front national 1972 fondé par
jean-marie le pen il faut voir sur quel
à partir de quel agrégats le front
national a été fondé afin de laisser au
renouveau notamment celle de fer avec la
croix celtique machin néo fasciste et
compagnie donc il ya il ya quand même au
fond de la bouteille ce vieux ce vieux
dépôt nauséabond alors kiki qui rend
l'homme qui donne un goût de piquette à
tous ce mauvais vin et puis qui remonte
de temps en temps quand on secoue
mais cela dit alors voilà il poursuivi
et condamné cinq fois pour les mêmes
propos il les réitère le parquet
poursuit de nouveau
enfin j'allais dire désespérée enfin ces
mêmes c'est pas drôle jean charles a
raison ce serait drôle c'est lui était
sympathique mais c'est pas franchement
personnage vraiment sympathique donc
enfin ça a un côté un peu désolant et
puis alors ratissé c'est néfaste pour le
front national ou que comme dit jean lui
que saab sera portée dé voir ratisser
les voix des pétainistes
aujourd'hui je le fais je pense pas que
ce soit une opération politique
extrêmement rentable presque dix ans
alors si les pétainistes existe encore
ils doivent être très vieux il ya aussi
des néo pétainiste chi chi chi le
mouvement le maurrassien la l'extrême
droite française enfin il a sa jouerie
les racines assez profonde là dedans
non c'est pas que ce soit énorme
florence vous avez quel absolument rien
à y gagner dont sept dans cette
opération là d'autant plus que je pense
que ça doit choquer un certain nombre de
nouveaux militants qui peuvent venir de
gauche de droite qui sont pas du tout
antisémite ou raciste et ça peuvent
franchement plutôt les faire un effet
repoussoir qu'autre chose quand alors
pardon juste une petite chose qui est ce
qui tuerait ils ont quand même un peu
gagné la famille le pen faguet gagné
sauf dans certains côtés parce que c'est
le seul parti politique quand on parle
de on parle de marine de jean-marie de
papy jeudi au plus personne tous les
autres à droite à gauche on parle non le
nom de famille des hommes politiques
là il ya une espèce de deux presque
d'amitié enfin glauque parce que dans la
rue marine et sympathique où le pas
sympathique et les aussi leur marion
était bien on ne parle que des prénoms
etc on a l'impression qu'ils sont
rentrés en en ou presque passé c'est une
famille nous réserve t on alors je fais
partie de la famille et moi j'avais pas
d'autres figures vrai que cette partie
de ma famille
ça me donne une marc-antoine mafia alors
le vieux regret qu'on a des familles
monarchique passé le mode le pouvoir
cndd fdd parti
oui absolument un beau jeu vous demander
d'être assez rapide parce que je vais
aborder le deuxième sujet bombe a pris
déjà beaucoup de temps ce qui est normal
puisque le la la la la question est
lourde sur la gauche alors je vais vous
poser la question directement est-ce que
vous pensez que la gauche a déjà perdu
les élections présidentielles je crois
je crois que la gauche doit boire le
calice jusqu'à la lie c'est à dire que
ça lui suffit pas encore et qu'il faut
et qu'il faut que le désastre se répète
pour que les gens à gauche je prenne
conscience qu'il faut recomposer et que
la structuration politique de la gauche
aujourd'hui ne signifie rien là on voit
bien qu'ils sont d'accord sur rien quoi
enfin il ya ceux qui disent il faut se
rassembler mais pour une politique plus
à gauche ceux qui disent il faut se
rassembler mais pour une politique qui
est plus de l'avant plus à plus à droite
la plus politique macro
donc on voit bien qu'ils sont tous
totalement coupée des réalités
économiques sociales du pays on voit
bien qu'ils s'en sont éloignés année
après année et que après de belles
promesses dont on sait bien qu'elles
n'ont pas été tenues aujourd'hui ces
gens là sont complètement par terre
alors maintenant il faut rendre visite
et refaire des bills sont extrêmement
divisés ils n'ont plus de lieu commun et
non plus de programme commun est ce qui
a fait le succès on le sait bien qu'elle
a été enlevée mais au delà de ça c'est
ce que disait c'était vraiment sûr tout
à l'heure c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
gagner une élection si on est tout seul
mais donc faut avoir la capacité de se
regrouper là on a l'impression qu'ils
veulent non plus il aime se regroupent
et ils ont des visions économiques qui
sont radicalement différentes
je crois que valls et macro ont compris
qu'il faut produire pour pouvoir ensuite
partagé sauf que à mon monde bossait il
faut d'abord partagé même si on produit
rien n'ont pas du tout la même vision et
du coup je vois pas comment ils peuvent
se retrouver sur quelque chose de commun
et c'est nécessairement je vois pas
comment ils vont faire autrement que des
guides aux dons lancé farid ou la folie
absolue depuis les années 70 de ne pas
avoir voulu d'un centre dans ce pays
or le centre avait pour vocation de
faire des alliances d'un côté les
institutions
c'était aujourd'hui on voit bien que
toute l'équipe valls et tout ce qui
l'entouré plutôt de centre gauche et un
certain nombre de partenaires de la
droite notamment l'idée est plutôt de
centre-droit c'est la série se veut sud
devait se faire la troisième voie c'est
à partir de ces idées au demeurant quand
on voit borloo dire que quelque part on
ne peut qu'admirer la le bonhomme les
idées qu'il défend la façon dont ils
traitent aujourd'hui à sa façon c'est un
bonheur aussi
en même temps raconté seulement il nous
nous payons nous payons aujourd'hui
d'avoir à tous à tous fera peut être
voulu casser la gueule de centres en
france
tout à fait d'accord stéphane daydé
florence tacitement non sur le sentons
pas du tout à ceci près que votre
question c'était pas du tout celle là
c'était ce que la gauche c'est fini oui
mais nous sommes en 2010 et encore il
est bon en 2017 en 2017 c'est
complètement différent parce que
visiblement la gauche comme à droite ne
pense qu'à une chose c'est d'être face
au candidat du front national
donc là ça ça change complètement ce que
la lieue de l'analyse de ces fadaises eu
tout à fait juste de florence
effectivement on peut on ne peut qu'être
d'accord mais en 2017
on risque encore en tout cas à l'heure
où on parle de d'avoir un candidat
démocratique
et puis face au front national donc là
ça change tout la valeur n'est pas
terrible donc la gauche aurait pris 50
gamelle d'ici là voyez ça changera rien
en fait mal quand même l'impression
qu'on partie celle ci dit s'il y avait
beaucoup qui ont déjà fait l'impasse sur
2017 et qui souhaitent la démo de la
défaite de françois hollande pour passer
à autre chose et faire quelque chose
d'autre en 2022 après il y en a bien sûr
mais après il ya eu une question d'âge
puisque après faut regarder la la
génération du ps et c'est vrai que quand
on loupe un tour comme la présidentielle
on prend tout de suite 5 ans voire 10
ans pour revenir en politique alors si
gens qui rêvent de faire la politique et
c'est très bien et heureusement qu'il y
en a mais du coup il dit bah oui si on
laisse tomber 2017
on aura soixante dix ans où on aura quel
âge auras ton quand on va récupérer le
pouvoir
donc c'est un vrai problème donc on
lâche pas si facilement que ça une
élection laurier eu l'élection des
présidents de conseils départementaux
peu de femmes
le disais tout à l'heure on va en parler
je propose de voir par exemple élections
dans les yvelines de pierre bédier et
blanc sans surprise un seul candidat
pour la présidence du nouveau conseil
départemental un conseil passez
entièrement à droite et un seul élu
pierre bédier et on retrouve ainsi son
fauteuil par 38 voix et 4 bulletins
blancs toutefois toute élection je voter
blanc revoyez d'organes a que trois une
importance aucune importance pas pour
tout le monde
la doyenne de l'assemblée christine
boutin y voit la marque de liberté
indispensable au sein d'une assemblée
unique aux leurs dans une assemblée
unicolore comme la nôtre il est
indispensable que nous ayons la liberté
la liberté de voter en conscience parce
que sinon ça risque de donner une image
très autoritaire et dictatorial de notre
assemblée
vous savez les hommes et les femmes
politiques ont très souvent tendance à
se mettre des boulets aux pieds alors
qu'on leur demande d'être libre or à
bien chacun à voter en toute liberté et
le président est très bien et lui très
bien et lui est bien entouré et pierre
bédier disposera de douze
vice-présidents et de 29 membres dans la
commission permanente une nouvelle façon
aussi de travailler dans une assemblée
renouvelée à 60% et qui marque l'entrée
de nombreux élus de notre secteur
joséphine cole basse berger devient
quatrième vice présidente
le président choisit effectivement on
voit c'est dès demain c'est une demande
que j'avais fait d'être dans la culture
je n'avais pas demandé particulièrement
je dirais une vice présidence je crois
que le fait que nous arrivions au niveau
des femmes dans cette parité fait aussi
je suis obligé de le dire nous donne ces
opportunités là donc je suis très très
fier très heureuse après cette première
séance les élus ont siégé en commission
ils auront peu de temps pour prendre
leurs marques
la prochaine séance et le 12 avril pour
le débat d'orientation budgétaire
le cap a d'ores et déjà été fixé par le
nouveau président
la solidarité parce que c'est notre
mission première
mais la solidarité sociale doit être
conjugué avec la solidarité territoriale
est aussi le combat à mener dans la
constitution du grand paris un danger
selon lui pour la grande couronne
parisienne
on est au combat c'est un combat
pacifique mais c'est la nécessité
vraiment de de peser dans tous les
débats tout de suite et cette assemblée
se mobilisent pour cela un autre moment
attend la nouvelle assemblée ce sera le
vote du budget 17 après on voit la
direction donc posé aucun problème que
ya pas eu d'ailleurs de problèmes dans
les élections de présidents de
départements je crois il ya la question
de l'essonne avec georges tron qui
finalement ne s'est pas présenté alors
qu'il avait mené la campagne électorale
on l'a dit au départ et à quoi à peu
près 10% à 2 2 femmes présidentes des
des départements contre 50 pour son
candidat ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
jean-luc jeu je m'adresse à vous parce
qu'il ya eu cette semaine un premier pas
dans le conflit qui oppose les hôteliers
les restaurateurs à booking.com hélas la
commission de la concurrence a été
saisie
est-ce que nous faire le point sur ce
conflit accueillant la concurrence pour
l'aso n'a pas dit grand chose et
booking.com quand tu n'existais alors je
voudrais juste quelques chiffres aussi
d'éclairer un peu le débat booking.com
qui est un des sites internet de
réservation il y en a d'autres
expédia hotels.com qui sont les plus
connus ces 750 mille réservation de
chambres d'hôtel par joue à jour dans le
monde
bon d'accord booking.com c'est quoi
c'est finalement une entreprise qui a
été créée grâce à de nouvelles
technologies dans le domaine numérique
qui permet avec des algorithmes de
pouvoir maîtriser une grande partie du
marché des réservations d'hôtels dans le
monde entier
ces algorithmes et l'ensemble de la
technologie extrêmement complexe
aujourd'hui est basée aux états unis et
les américains se sont bien gardés
d'exporter leur savoir faire dans ce
domaine
alors c'est quoi booking.com ou
hotels.com ou expedia pour le domaine
de l'hôtellerie mais on peut également
parler des domaines de la restauration
avec la fourchette et tripadvisor ou on
pourrait parler des domaines du
transport des personnes avec hubert bla
bla bla bla point com etc
j'en passe c'est quoi c'est en réalité
l'émergence d'une nouvelle organisation
du commerce
on appelle ça d'ailleurs le e-commerce
c'est quoi l'implication qu'il peut y
avoir derrière pour les opérateurs de
services comme de sommes-nous hôteliers
restaurateurs c'est que un produit qui
vaut sans la plateforme internet vous
dit nous nous allons mettre en marché
mais on va le mettre en marché à 70
parce qu'on considère que si vous voulez
de notre aide
il faut que vous fassiez les prix
d'accord donc ça va de 30 à 50% ce qui
est déjà considérable pour n'importe
quel opérateur quelle que soit la nature
de son commerce par dessus cela non
seulement on vous pousse à vendre un
produit qui vaut 170 mais par le ce
marché on vous prend en moyenne 20 % de
commission sur le produit en question ce
qui veut dire que sur son disque et ça
ça fait quatorze d'accord donc un
produit qui est affichée sans
l'opérateur prend 56 il laisse 44 une
grande partie dans le domaine discount
et une grande partie dans le domaine de
la commission vous imaginez bien que
n'importe quel commerçant normalement
constitué quand il a un produit qu'il a
affichée sans et que ne lui rapporte
plus que 56 saadé mon slam en direct sur
un certain nombre de problématiques
d'entreprise de gestion et bien entendu
un impact direct sur le mal être du
personnel à la fois le recrutement mais
aussi son niveau de rémunération sur les
investissements sur le développement
bref ça a un impact terriblement
important et ça s'est fait de façon
extrêmement rapide sur l'ensemble des
services et pourquoi pourquoi il est
l'heure les hôteliers les restaurateurs
ou parce qu'ils n'ont pas vu venir non
seulement ils n'ont pas vu venir mais je
dirais que globalement les corps
intermédiaires auquel vous savez que je
suis extrêmement attachée se dire les
organisations professionnelles n'ont pas
vu venir le coup
les hôteliers qui pointent une grande
partie d'entre eux se sont dit tiens
pourquoi pas est ce qu on sait ça
remplit ses salles en pro
voir nos nuitées sur les lundi mardi ou
c'est pas terriblement a fait rêver ça
remplit donc voilà donc un manque pas
mal certain temps nous avons accepté les
uns les autres de jouer ce jeu là est
très vite on s'est rendu compte que
c'était un jeu de dupes
parce que précisément et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons alerté le toit
de la concurrence grâce aux
organisations professionnelles dans
lesquelles vous le savez je suis à
présent temps nous avons dit stop
c'est un massacre donc il faut
absolument que nous remettions vous
attendez quoi nous attendons simplement
que les opérateurs internet remette de
l' équilibre dans la mise en marché de
nos produits ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'à un moment donné si nous
considérons que nous pouvons reprendre
la main sur les briques non pratiquants
sur nos produits et bien les opérateurs
internet peut nous aider mais pour
autant ne pas mixer de l'année même
aujourd'hui il se trouve que booking.com
qui est le premier opérateur dans ce
domaine a pris la main non seulement sur
les prix mais également sur les
plannings de réservation dans un grand
nombre d'établissements mais aussi sur
les marques ses vertus aujourd'hui si
vous vous appelez l'hôtel de la gare à
telle brique sur mer si vous cherchez un
hôtel à telgruc sur mer
vous allez vraiment vraiment par boualem
seulement ça le terminer ça veut dire
que grâce à leur à une mécanique
absolument extraordinaire du progrès
dans ce domaine ont été mais vraiment
spectaculaire et on n'a rien vu venir
eh bien il achètent le nom de votre
hôtel et donc vous n'avez plus la main
ni sur notre marque ni cheveu planning
ni surpris vous imaginez à quel niveau
de dangerosité nous sommes arrivés
donc on est on a demandé un autographe
concurrence de travailler sur le sujet
honnêtement ils résident pas à ces trois
provinces ailleurs parce que cela dit
tout ça est vraiment intéressant et très
bien d'expliquer mais ce qui intéresse
le l'internaute et le pont royal
le consommateur sait moins c'est de
payer moins cher mais c'est surtout ce
qu'il attire c'est la différence entre
l'offre et de prix entre le prix réel
la proposition est ce qui va payer donc
j'imagine qu'il ya sûrement des
restaurateurs dont une est pas un peu
filou qui sont doubles toute façon on va
proposer un menu à 150 de toute façon on
aura une réduction de 60% sur le machin
et on va vendre 60 60 euros ce qui
toutes façons nous
1 donc je pense qu'il va utiliser par
exemple ce genre de plateforme
j'utilise surtout du beurre comme on en
parle et tout ça mais c'est un peu la
moue sur pas c'est un peu les taxis on
ne sait pas ce qu'il espère faire vous
avez le jeu bravo qui savait qu'on parle
du numérisation de la société ce qui est
inventé sa nourriture qui ferment loue
son service et sont des nuls à
destination du consommateur du client
java du coup payer la course 30 ou 40%
moins cher at il acheté une licence non
non pas utile at-il l'obligation de
faire un truc aussi mais je comprends ce
serait pour le consommateur doit donner
et c'est là justement que nous demandons
à l'administration
j'ai certainement android donc de
regarder le prime avec un terrain parce
que on ne peut pas laisser perdurer des
systèmes qui sont en train de mettre par
terre
des pans entiers de notre économie et
pas seulement en france mais on peut
mettre par terre le planter des taxis je
veux dire la france on relèvera très
bien ne t'inquiètes n'y a aucun souci je
n'aurais pas quand cela ne me sens pas
le droit d'aller stigmatiser les taxis
moi j'en avais remarqué je me sens le
droit de dire qu'effectivement les taxis
qui eux ont vu le coup venir
depuis longtemps aurait dû depuis
longtemps s'adapter mais n'ont pas fait
de bons donc aujourd'hui mois qui suit
vous l'avez simplement noté impliqué
dans le syndicalisme patronal
j'essaye évidemment de lutter pour avoir
un bon équilibre oui bien entendu que
les taxis doivent se remettre en
question mais en même temps on peut pas
laisser sur ce ver de valmer dans le var
la france bookeen femme trouve ça très
commode donc mais je comprends très bien
ce que dit jean luc et qui a
probablement un point la wii la raison
pour laquelle j'ai passé par beaucoup
mais c'est difficile parce que le
premier le premier jeu serait qu'elle
vous tombez c'est vous qui cherchez
confessionnelles à nice sur des sur
surbooking qui est encore en premier
maintenant sur le problème de hubert qui
est un peu différente de deux bons
matches même si un peu parce que le
fameux king je sais pas si on peut dire
que booking prend la place
oui boeing doivent donc ça va là il se
soit pas les clients mais surtout le
moine des hôteliers comme un peu
différent hubert ils ce sont des gens
qui font le métier à la place des taxis
sans avoir effectivement payés dix ans
que ça à moitié d'accord pour dire que
les chauffeurs de taxis doivent se
remettre en question au 6 et y reste
voilà il faut qu'ils se modernise faut
qu'il faut s'adapter un peu à
l'évolution de notre temps et les
chauffeurs taxis du ceci on peut râler
sur paris parce qu'il y en a pas c'est
parce que etc et si mme hubert à trouver
forcément hubert ou itx aussi parce que
c'est aussi non médiation qu'ils ont
rempli ils auront critères besoin parce
que chercher un taxi al rai
le soir ou la nuit c'est un peu
compliqué juste pour finir là-dessus la
problématique du beurre et de hitch
c'est qu'il y a un on est pas certain
qu'ils soient assurés et ça c'est un
vrai problème et sur reach soudan et 10
si jamais on est contrôlé aucun accident
vous dit qu'on est amis ah oui et donc
ce qu'ils peuvent que les quand même un
peu un peu moyen sur le stéphanois sans
sur ce système mais puisqu'on parle des
corps intermédiaires il moi je vois le
corps intermédiaires auquel j'appartiens
avec fierté
au delà de la fonction publique de
l'état c'est l'université à l'université
alors je ne sais pas vous dire qu'on est
touché mais parce qu'on est aussi acteur
il ya le phénomène des moux et massive
6 c'est à dire des cours massif ouvert
en ligne alors on ne jure que par cela
le ministère a lancé la norme qui
s'appelle d'où vient le nom d'ailleurs
il ya à peu près 300 mille quatre cent
mille abonnés à 7
cette plateforme là ça suscite de très
lourds de questions aussi sur nos
méthodes d'enseignement mais il ya en
tout cas une
il voulait une une conclusion très
provisoire parce que le système évolue
c'est que on est très difficile
d'autonomiser 1
on appelle ça un apprenant devant seul
seul devant son ordinateur et ça on sait
que ça marche pas on sait que ça marche
pour ceux qui ont déjà une étoffe sa
gamme assez importante mais on sait que
c'est assez largement pipeau tout cela à
condition alors si on veut que ça marche
il faut y mettre des moyens qui sont
très très long
frans hals autres parce qu'on n'est pas
sur le phénomène de la gratuité mais
c'est quand même sur le phénomène de la
baisse des prix de voilà exactement ça
c'était quelque chose qui me terrifie
absolument c'est qu'on est en train de
d'instiller dans la tête des gens que
tout doit être gratuit que plus rien ne
doit se payer les livres le cinéma fin
de la dernière avanie enfin d'une
culture lcd cinéma qui propose qu'on
sent l'ail
si le haut boudeulle d'un produit si
longtemps le fils du soleil film n'est
pas bien elle se rembourser son ticket
mais c'est une aberration enfin pau
c'est une déresponsabilisation sur un
scandale après on est gratuite on est au
cours de nuit 10 q et puis les choses
doivent se payer fuir l'université à un
coût relativement minime mais je veux
c'est quasi gratuit voilà maintenant
c'est ce que j'ai dit non non non mais
je veux dire bon mais les 150 181
végétation de ces coûte à la
collectivité 6000 euros
non c'était pas du tout une attaque
contre 91 blessés c'est très bien mais
parce qu'il ya l'état n'est rien mais
sinon qu'après je dire toutes les choses
doivent se payer
jeudi on doit payer quand on va au
restaurant on doit payer quand on va à
l'hôtel on doit payer si on prend une
voiture et on n'arrête pas de faire
croire que tout est gratuit
c'est venu à mon avis avec le téléphone
portable on a l'équipe et tous nos
enfants et tout ceci équipés et avec la
télévision le front triple play triple
play par n'ont cessé débité sur votre
compte en banque plus personne ne sait
ce que c'est que cette somme qui vous
est pris tout le moins on a une
impression de gratuité qui est fausse
mais du coup on se dit bas le tout tout
ça est gratuit l'heureuse le reste va
les trouver jean est ce que c'est un mal
nécessaire ce qui voudrait faire avec où
est-ce qu'on peut lutter contre ça et ce
qu'il faut lutter conte alors oui on
peut lutter contre ça j'ose dire
pourquoi très vite parce qu'il restait
bien l'entré deux mers booking.com ces 5
milliards de dollars de revenus par an
il n'y a pas un dollar qui revient à
l'état français n'ont donc un rendez
vous quand même des barrières et dire ok
ce problème existe il va falloir lutter
sur deux points le premier être moins
gourmand de commissions permettre aux
hôteliers de vente au prix normal leur
chambre d'hôtel aux restaurateurs de
vendre au prix normal leurs couverts et
les marges faites par ces opérateurs une
partie au moins doit revenir
évidemment pour
développement des établissements pour
lesquels ils dépensent autant d'énergie
donc il va falloir rééquilibrer tout ça
et c'est ce qu'ils appellent ils
pourraient pas se mettre d'accord pour
dire non alors précisément rejugé
apporter la somme de documents
reddick bac et une boîte d'île de france
explique qu'il boit d'ile-de-france
ferme ou king une boîte française lui
d'ores et déjà et ce pour faire booking
depuis quasiment trois ans pour essayer
de se substituer à ces plateformes
sauf que malheureusement là les pouvoirs
publics qui ont la main sur le sujet en
france ne met pas les moyens nécessaires
si je vous disais le budget alloué par
la région ile-de-france sur le
développement de la technologie
numérique c'est juste à pleurer de honte
donc il est grand temps que nous nous
occupions de ces sujets c'est marrant
selon lui qu'à des moments il veut plus
de règles et puis là il veut plus d'eux
il est bien un conseil de la reine de
sicile c'est mon nom c'est de l'aide
nous y avait des contradictions
l'intérieur de nous-mêmes on achète des
actions booking point que c'est fini sur
ces sujets bah je vous remercie tous les
tous les cinq
puis j'espère vous retrouver très vite
pour un nouveau pack mercier beaucoup
avec nous c'était très bien bon bah tant
pis merci infiniment